et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois billets lesage pédiatre membres
du groupe de vaccinologie infovac
bonsoir fabrice sa division avocats de
nombreux soignants notamment dans cette
crise ducobu bonsoir fabrice di vizio
merci d'être avec nous également
paul thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france qui
demande nous parler de la partie plus
européenne de ces vaccins puisque le
royaume uni a donné son feu vert à la
vaccination
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'être
avec nous donc on a entendu une
stratégie dévoilée à 1 ce soir par le
premier ministre un exercice de
communication qui se présente comme
anticipé réfléchit on ne veut pas
commettre les mêmes erreurs que par le
passé fabrice division pourrait tout dit
un exercice de communication
voilà nous avons assisté encore et
toujours à un exercice de communication
depuis le départ dans cette crise nous
assistons à des exercices de
communication alors peut-être qu'un jour
on fera autre chose communiqué mais
c'est pas pour tout de suite et le
problème effectivement toujours le même
c'est que nous communiquons à tort et à
travers et dans cette affaire de
vaccination si l'objectif une emporter
l'adhésion de la population
bah c'est mal parti vous le
le défenseur des vaccins françois vivier
lesage vous avez trouvé cet exercice
alors certes de communication mais quand
même avec du fond est indispensable et
plutôt bien mené par le premier ministre
aujourd'hui et ses ministres
plutôt bien d'ailleurs c'est un exercice
de communication parce que c'est
certainement la plus importante des
choses à faire actuellement
alors je me félicite déjà d'une première
chose c'est que ça soit alain fischer
qui qu'ils étaient
désigné pour diriger cela car il fait
l'unanimité dans les milieux médicaux et
scientifiques c'est un grand un grand
scientifique qui a beaucoup travaillé
sur les problèmes d'immunité de l'enfant
et sur les déficits immunitaires
il a mené aussi la concertation
citoyenne sur la politique vaccinale en
et c'est un homme très compétent et
qu'il ya une éthique absolument
irréprochable il va falloir alors je
vois fabrice di vizio kiki qui dit non
de la tête fabrice di vizio vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec cette analyse de
françois billets lesage sur le nouveau
monsieur vaccins dans mais non mais je
connais pas monsieur max ans et je m'en
fiche en fait je m'en fiche complètement
je croyais qu'on avait un conseil
scientifique le conseil scientifique
illégaux dans cette affaire je comprends
pas pour combien de temps nous allons
continuer à mettre des str ap les unes
sur les autres dans cette affaire je
veux dire nous avons un premier ministre
et un président de la république nos
remises de la santé parce qu'on a encore
un c'est pas sûr on a un directeur de
l'année cette annonce est vraiment là
plus qu'ailleurs on a effectivement un
conseil scientifique
ah bah non apparemment non plus dire à
un moment si vous voulez moi je trouve
ça incroyable qu'on se réjouissent du
fait que c'est un exercice de
communication
n'avez-vous donc pas compris à quel
point est-ce qu'on est déconnecté dans
ce pays qu'on n'a plus confiance dans un
gouvernement on n'a plus confiance
vous avez vu effectivement ce qui fait
passer avec leur m18 vire vous avez vu
les couacs monumentaux que ça va générer
vous avez vu les problématiques autour
du masque on nous a menti pendant des
mois et aujourd'hui vous avez raison
c'est un acte majeur la vaccination mais
c'est parce que c'est un acte majeur
qu'il faut effectivement prendre le
temps et ne pas se précipiter et dans
cette affaire on nous explique que c'est
un acte réfléchi mais rien n'est
réfléchi dans cette crise c'est le drame
yannick noah enfants fabrice di vizio on
en parlera d'ailleurs avec pas le
thomson dans dans quelques instants on
n'est pas les plus rapides je vous
rassure tout de suite françois vivier
lesage me disais voilà un exercice de
communication indispensable peut-être
parce que nous sommes les français parmi
les plus sceptiques ans selon un sondage
dans l'exclusif ifop fiducial pour ses
news et puis et sud radio une large
majorité de français en 61 % n'ont pas
du tout l'intention de se faire vacciner
contre le coronavirus je vous propose
d'écouter justement le ministre de la
santé tout à l'heure olivier
on commence déjà essayé de convaincre
les français et les rassurer une chose
est sûre c'est que la peur du vaccin
n'arrêtera pas le virus ni celui ci ni
les autres nous nous appuierons donc sur
des agences sanitaires indépendante dont
c'est le métier dans ce sont les
fonctions l'émission dans la durée pour
qu'elles s'assurent que nous puissions
vacciner dans de bonnes conditions et
comme l'a dit le premier ministre notre
rôle c'est de mettre à disposition le
bon vaccin au bon patient au bon moment
la prudence et l'objectivité doivent
donc que nous guider temps dans le
déploiement dans le déploiement
progressif de la vaccination que dans le
suivi que nous organiserons françois
vivier lesage c'est vraiment ce qu'on
attend parmi les défenseurs du vaccin en
a même beaucoup évidemment parmi les
scientifiques la plupart il faut cet
exercice de pédagogie indispensable la
part du gouvernement ce virage n'est pas
rater mais il est pas rater il est raté
plus ou moins quand on fait une
communication il ya celui qui parle est
celui qui écoute bon je suis pas là pour
faire de la polémique avec un avocat qui
à mon avis d un parti pris et n'est pas
là pour savoir comment il va falloir
faire avancer les choses moi je suis là
en tant que scientifiques et médecins
confrontés au vide pour l'instant
directement alors je suis pédiatre donc
je suis pas forcément le plus confrontés
puisque c'est surtout les ehpad qui sont
ce qu'ils sont que sont confrontées les
personnes âgées dont je suis il est
important il y à il ya une urgence
sanitaire est une urgence médicale
nous en tant que scientifique aux
analyses sur les débats nous ne comptons
pas d'analyser les communiqués de presse
de savoir quelle est l'utilisation
politique où il est idéologique qui en
est faite
ce qui est important pour nous c'est
d'avoir des données alors les données je
vous rappelle qu'un vaccin en général
ces cinq à dix ans pour être mieux pour
être développées ici
les scientifiques ont eu moins d'un an
et
quel que soit d'ailleurs les pays où ça
a été fait depuis la chine jusqu'aux
états unis en passant par l'europe et
les anglais il ya eu un mouvement
scientifique absolument extraordinaire
je suis pas là pour des formes de
gouvernement
excusez moins de ceux de vision mais ce
n'est pas mon sujet je suis pas là dans
la polémique
celui-là est ce que les vaccins sont
efficaces est-ce que les vaccins vont
être utiles à qui faut-il les faire
je pense que c'est ça le problème
principal je pense que c'est là dessus
que nous travaillons nous et s'ils
voulaient qu'on en discute on discute
mais je pense bat sur les manières de
discuter du gouvernement pas le comme ça
que je suis une petite question vous
l'anglais à paris vous êtes étonnés de
ce scepticisme très français parce qu'on
a vu que les britanniques eux on en
reparlera en plus en détails après du
cas du royaume-uni mais les britanniques
étaient ravis d'avoir ce vaccin pour la
plupart et kourou se faire vacciner
c'est un débat qui se trouvent dans
nombreux pays en allemagne aux états
unis en angleterre aussi donc je pense
que si j'avais cité un pourcentage à
propos du scepticisme d'aider des
français qui est peut-être plus élevé
que dans d'autres pays
naissent deux phénomènes on lui même
n'est pas exclusivement français loin de
là ils existent aussi en angleterre tant
qu'homme je pense que ça va je ne suis
pas du tout aussi scientifique moi même
am je
se pose que cela repose sur fait il ya
eu un cas après dix ans d'une à vaccin
qui a fait 4 dégâts et pour ceux qui ne
sont pas de formation scientifique dont
je suis encore une fois ça peut inspirer
une certaine crainte ou ou d'étude en ce
qui me concerne je préférerais à me
faire vacciner sans un instant
d'hésitation mais bon ça ça n'engage que
moi même
pour récapituler ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui est unique à la france ça ne
ment pas sabri division sans bouillir
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai une question
à poser à votre invité est effectivement
qui n'est pas là pour défendre le
gouvernement mais un peu quand même
donc c'est de savoir est-ce que
effectivement monsieur vous avez vu les
études sur le vaccin ça m'intéresse
beaucoup de le savoir est ce que vous
pouvez ce soir certifié aux français que
ce vaccin dont vous avez vu les études
vous êtes médecin vous êtes donc un
spécialiste des vaccins parce que c'est
en cette qualité que vous exprimer je
dirais donc avec vous effectivement
contrairement à éric comme qui lui n'a
vu que les communiqués de presse
contrairement à catherine hill qui
manifestement ne les a pas vu non plus
contrairement au conseil scientifique
est ce que vous ce soir vous pouvez dire
aux français sur une chaîne oui j'ai ouï
français à 60 millions de français vous
pouvez vous faire vacciner sans vis je
prends la responsabilité personnelle des
études en qualité de médecin je les ai
vus je les ai vu un
parce qu'à un moment donné il faut aussi
assumer je les ai vus mois éric comme
neda pas vu mais moi je les ai vus et à
ce titre je vous dis eh bien
effectivement tout ça est parfaitement
cadré ses 100 ans avec comme question
il est bien sûr avec un qui va beaucoup
mieux que moi
le
vous connaissez pas très bien la
démarche scientifique je pense
la première première chose c'est d'avoir
des études scientifiques que nous
attendons je n'hésite pas mais s'il vous
plaît je vous réponds à vos questions
non je ne peux pas vous devez laisser
leur répondez vous
on veut lui avais voit la france à une
question il va ré tronçon pas dans un
tribunal monsieur je suis là j'essaye
d'aider à régler de temps à part ma
petite personne
la crise qu'on entend on concourt donc
là là l'évolution surtout quand je vois
qu'on peut parlement pourra discuter
avec ce monsieur dont claudine
chercheurs voient la beauté noter aussi
les noms visés aussi un tribunal chacun
est là pour donner son avis non mais
s'il se plaît voilà on va donner chacun
son avis très calmement six 6 mois ça
m'intéresse françois biais lesage votre
avis on vous laisse répondre sereinement
s'il vous plaît donc ma réponse serait
né très est très claire c'est non à
l'heure actuelle nous n'avons pas les
données scientifiques complètes qui
permettent d'avoir un avis complet ce
qu'il ya c'est que ça s'est fait très
rapidement n'avons pour l'instant que
des communiqués de presse avec quelques
résultats qui sont encourageants mais
sur lequel nous n'avons pas toutes les
données
ces données vont être données suivant un
parcours normal aux agences de santé
qu'elle soit européenne cependant
qu'elle à la sauce et la fin de l'ennemi
et qui est la société du médicament
européen
l'achat est ce aussi et ça a été donnée
très certainement un hs anglais aussi
qu'ils vont avoir des dossiers les
dossiers de ce qu'on appelle des mêmes
autorisations de mise sur le marché qui
ont qui ont des procédures d'urgence
vont être données à ces à ses agences
officielles qui vont les étudier en
détail je peux vous dire que c'est
d'être aigres son très gros dossiers qui
vont être étudiées l'autorisation ne
sera remis qu'à partir de là nous nous
attendons probablement
mi-décembre d'avoir les articles publié
des articles publiés mais même quand
nous aurons les données de ces articles
à les dossiers qui sont dans les agents
seront beaucoup plus importantes donc on
ne va pas mettre le gouvernement va pas
mettre sur le marché des vaccins comme
ça qu'ils n'en auront pas été testés
maintenant ça sera de toute façon une
efficacité à court terme pour l'instant
faut pas oublier et c'est monsieur cet
avocat qui a l'air d'oublier que le
vaccin à 2 2 deux objectifs à l'intérêt
individuel et à l'intérêt collectif dans
l'urgence et l'intérêt individuel c'est
à dire ce sont des personnes âgées qui
sont dans les ehpad dont la mortalité
est très importante avec cette maladie
qui doivent être vaccinés en urgence et
c'est pour ça que là ce qui compte c'est
une efficacité à court terme
on a déjà des satisfactions pour les
protéger ces gens là dans un deuxième
temps il faudra voir l'intérêt collectif
c'est à dire le fait d'essayer de
juguler cette pandémie cette épidémie en
vaccinant au moins 50 60 % voire la
population avec d'autres vaccins
possiblement moins cher et qui ont
d'autres efficacité on attend d'avoir
les données mais ni moi ni personne ni
monsieur fisher d'ailleurs ne sont
capables pour l'instant de donner des
réponses précises mais les données vont
arriver dans les quinze jours
mais si notre avocat préféré ce soir à
toutes les données là dessus et c'est
qu'il ne faut pas vacciner que les gens
peuvent continuer à mourir dans les
hôpitaux on va donner la cervelle aussi
à apa le thomson ticket calé au milieu
voilà monsieur mourinho ne pardonnez moi
quand même des choses sont suffisamment
graves pour que je vous avais fait qu'on
a partie de la sorte géré monsieur vient
vous expliquer effectivement pour sa
part qu'il n'a pas les données et c'est
légitime et c'est honnête de le
reconnaître
alors effectivement d excuser moi
avaient interpellé des gens qui se
posent des questions
de la sorte c'est juste malhonnête mais
c'est pas grave alors paul thompson vous
en angleterre en royaume uni 1 c'est la
fin du confinement et l'annoncent du
vexin c'était un peu l'euphorie
hier et
gensse de santé britannique on est dans
le sujet dit elle avoir respecté à la
lettre les mêmes normes que l'union
européenne pour autoriser le vaccin est
ce que vous en savez plus justement sur
les raisons pour laquelle c'est aller
beaucoup plus vite
en grande bretagne ce que j'ai lu dans
la presse parce qu'encore une fois je ne
suis pas une experte en la matière c'est
que il y avait deux facteurs qui ont pu
permettre l'aboutissement rapide d'une
part l'exécutif a damné à l'exécutif
politique j'entends à donner une
impulsion politique pour que ce soit
c'était très rapidement et deuxièmement
les apparemment dans la façon de
travailler des équipes un ticket au
royaume uni il ya une âme implication
volontaire des différentes étapes donc
l'étape de lancers pendant que l'étape
une toujours en cours mais on a une
intègre au fur à mesure des résultats de
l'état une qu'il faut dans l'étape 2 et
ainsi de suite et apparemment cette
façon de procéder qui n'est pas utilisée
aux états unis par exemple où ils en
sont et étanchéité entre les états
d'après ce que j'ai lu à permettre
d'accélérer sensiblement serait une
explication alors il ya une autre
explication c'est celle de m un coq le
ministre de la santé qui s'étaient
laissés enfin qui sait qui c'est et
c'est plutôt aller à dire que c'était un
petit peu de grâce au break si je vous
propose d'écouter un matin coque
grâce au prêt exit nous avons pu prendre
une décision fondée sur le régulateur
britannique un régulateur de classe
mondiale et nous on rythme des européens
qui avance un peu plus lentement un
françois billets lesage ça vous inspire
quoi ce genre de réflexion on a subi une
forme de poids de l'administration
européenne dans dans cette affaire des
vaccins
pas le premier à le dire en
effectivement m voilà je ne parle pas en
tant que journaliste politique au niveau
scientifique si vous voulez les anglais
ont toujours été plutôt en avance au
niveau stratégie politique vaccinale ils
ont souvent souvent démarré dès des
politiques de vaccination par exemple
sur les méningites à méningocoques bien
avant le reste de l'europe et donc de ce
côté là en particulier le centre
d'oxford qui travaillaient que
astrazeneca sont toujours en point au
niveau de la recherche ce que dit notre
ami anglais c'est que c'est vrai que
c'est vrai un peu partout c'est à dire
que les phases de développement des
vaccins ont été forcément raccourci est
souvent chevauchée puisque bas on
n'avait pas 5 à 10 ans pour le
développer c'est ce qu'on avait déjà eu
on a déjà lu cette expérience avec le
vaccin ebola ce que j'en ai lu mais par
un jeu là je sais moi qui ne suis pas du
tout un expert en politique anglaise
c'est que je crois que le premier
ministre anglais a été démentie par la
directrice de la deûle agence l' agence
du médicament anglaise parce que en fait
les lois du break si des lois de
européenne s'applique jusqu'au 1er
janvier
mais ce n'est pas ma spécialité je veux
pas rentrer là dedans et que donc ça
changeait pas grand chose avec la loi
européenne il pouvait tout à fait faire
ce qu'ils ont fait alors est ce que en
plus de donner c'est ça qui m'intéresse
pour démarrer plus vite de cette
vaccination
honnêtement ça je ne sais pas donc quand
je ne sais pas je dis que je sais pas
alors je sentirais sedan mais vous avez
raison vers le camp c'est vrai qu'on
parle beaucoup c'est pas le seul un pdg
de moderna l'avait évoquée renaud
muselier d'ailleurs aussi le poids de
l'administration en europe qui fait que
parfois les autorisations sont plus
difficiles à obtenir fabrice di vizio
c'est plutôt une une bonne chose que les
autorisations soient difficiles à
obtenir
parce qu'il faut afficher de la prudence
vous le disiez depuis des buts débat
avec beaucoup de d'antras je dis moi
mais vous vivez pas dans le monde même
je suis désolé messieurs dames mais vous
ne vivez pas dans le même monde que moi
donc je ne peux pas gouré c'est ce qui a
fait la différence et c'est très bien
ben non mais vous ne vivez pas dans le
même monde que moi parce que moi j'ai
une agence européenne à qui je reproche
effectivement de s'asseoir sur les
données de sécurité le rem dibir en est
un bon exemple
on a acheté des lots des lots et des
lots de raismes daisy vire alors
qu'effectivement on savait on savait au
moment où ça a été acheté que c'était
pas efficace quatrième quelqu'un karine
lacombe devant la commission denquête
l'avait dit donc ce que karine là qu'on
savait l'agencé européenne du médicament
ne savais pas manifestement la france ne
le savait pas non plus au travers de la
tpu donné et aujourd'hui effectivement
vous m'expliquer que tout ça c'est quand
même très ralentie l'agencé européenne
du médicament
finalement prend son temps et monsieur
nous explique effectivement que quand il
ne sait pas il dit qu'il ne sait pas
mais il vous explique quand même qu'il
ne sait rien et qu'il dit tout et que
sur les vaccins pour l'instant pas
concrètement il ne sait rien il n'a pas
les données mais que nul doute que quand
ce sera refait quand ce sera le temps de
vacciner on les aura il ya plus qu elle
espérait paul thompson ça vous inspire
quoi ce genre de débats très français
c'est vrai qu'il ya une défiance envers
les autorités un particulièrement en
france
en ce moment vous constatez la même
chose ou comme dit fabrice division
finalement on est sur une autre planète
réunis il y a deux débats très violent
mais sur des sujets économiques les
anglais sont obsédés par la vie
économique comme chacun sait est à et
donc il ya des débats même à l'intérieur
du parti conservateur eut admis mais les
intellectuels quito du centre et de la
droite il ya de viron
bagarres sur des questions importantes
aux roms la bonne voie a trouvé entre
d'une part bien protéger les citoyens et
d'autre part ne pas casser la vie
économique
est ce que j'en déduis très simplement
c'est que cette cette pandémie intex
exogènes pour tout le monde ça crée une
stress quasi universelle qui chacun la
vie de sa propre façon mais ce ce stress
se dégage de différentes manières dans
différentes pays différents contextes
mais je pense que certes il ne faut pas
trop s'en émouvoir qu'il ya des
désaccords et que c'est que ce désaccord
peut prendre une tonalité un peu vive
parce que le sujet en lui même est
extrêmement important et concerne
seulement et est donc on se sent tous
concernés et un peu désemparés en même
temps parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'inconnues effectivement et donc
j'attends bataille comme il peut pour
essayer dé d'ivoire cas je vois mon
petit commentaire sur votre question on
va terminer sur cette parole
d'apaisement en tout cas voilà les
opinions étaient toutes présentes sur ce
plateau merci beaucoup françois vielles
lesage fabrice di vizio également et
paul thompson d'avoir été avec nous pour
commenter notamment cette allocution du
premier ministre qui a lancé présenté sa
stratégie de campagne de vaccination
merci à tous les trois